ola rondiak is ukrainian-american artist
who divides her time between kiev and
new york since russia's invasion she
spends most of her time at local
protests and waiting for news of her
friends and family back home in ukraine
including her husband a u.s citizen who
managed to escape to romania we love
ukraine very loyal to ukraine and he
didn't want to desert
his people he wanted to stay as long as
possible but
he also knew he could do a lot from
being over the border
viselka a ukrainian restaurant in the
heart of the east village has long been
an enclave for the diaspora the third
generation ukrainian-american owner
summed up the mood we're saddened we're
we're frightened we're concerned we're
angry we're upset and it's just really a
very difficult time for us the
restaurant has become an unofficial
meeting spot for those who want to show
support for ukraine
just down the street from the restaurant
new york's ukrainian museum
its director feels the museum has been
given added importance in the wake of
vladimir putin's comment that ukraine is
quote not a real country ukraine
is a separate country has its own
history has its own culture
protests against the russian invasion of
ukraine are daily occurrences in new
york home to an estimated
000 ukrainians more than anywhere else
in the united states
the longer this war goes on the harder
it has become for ukrainians abroad to
watch from afar as their country
continues to be attacked
gabrielle zondo al jazeera new york